To alleviate all of that typing, JavaScript provides the keyword new.
Whenever we choose to use the keyword new in front of a function invocation,
our function is going to run in a special mode called Constructor Mode.
In that mode, we can expect a lot of this work to be done for us automatically.
So what is Construction Mode exactly?
Basically, it's a way for your interpreter to insert a few lines of
operations into your code because it knows that you're going to need them to
be done whenever you're instantiating a new object.
It temporarily makes your function run as if there was some extra code at
the beginning and end.
Even though you will never have typed that code.
The operations it's going to insert are basically doing
the same work as the lines you're likely to write in your prototypal classes.
So because we're using the key word new here, we can expect this invocation of
Car to run with these extra operations inserted at the beginning and at the end.
Whereas here, where the key word new does not show up in front of the invocation
of Car, these lines of code would not be inserted.
So in the same program, we can expect this one function to be run with and
without these inserted lines of code.
Remember, they will never actually show up in the code as you type it.
They only get run as a result of the fact that we are using the keyword new
right before this particular invocation.
Now even though I'm showing two different lines of code, one with and one
without the keyword new, you would never do such a thing in your own programs.
You're going to write functions that you expect to be run with the keyword new,
or not run with it.
But you would never write a function that you may or
may not use the keyword new with.
The purpose of it is to allow you to skip some of the work you're already doing.
So, once you decide to use the keyword new with a given function,
there's some inevitable refactoring you're going to have to do.
I've added the keyword new to both cases, and
I think it's time we delete some of the code we don't need anymore,
since we know this is how we intend to run the function